so let's get started well I was trying
to think about how to really describe
JavaScript if somebody fell off a cave
into a cave let's say back about 20
years ago and they just rescued this
person and the first question he asks is
what's the most popular language you're
gonna say well JavaScript of course and
the person is going to be an absolute
denial and I was thinking about how to
describe JavaScript and the only way I
can describe JavaScript is it's like
this bad villain in a movie they keep
killing him but he keeps coming back to
life and that's amazing how javascript
their surface so many different times
well I'm gonna talk a little bit about
what's really wrong with JavaScript to
begin with well one of the very first
problems with JavaScript is it's the
inconsistencies of the language across
different browsers we keep running into
errors all the time
and it's a very really poor name for a
language think about this for a minute
would you ever do this would you name
your child after somebody who's popular
in the neighborhood what a bad name for
the language called Java however because
it does become popular well there was a
really a poor name
it's a misunderstood language to a great
extent and a lot of times people really
fear this language but it's actually a
pretty powerful this and there's one
other problem I think we all run into
you typically go take probably a course
on how to program Java or C sharp or F
sharp but how many times people actually
take a course on JavaScript we feel kind
of insulted if somebody says go take a
course on JavaScript so how does morph
most people learn JavaScript well you
learn JavaScript by reading code on the
web and most of the JavaScript code on
the web is pure crap so we've been
learning from really bad examples in
fact I would say that's not true anymore
that was ten years ago but people have
shots are cured this now so we announced
simply copy and paste the bad code now
it's even worse than actually rewriting
that code so we haven't really taken the
time to learn this language really well
and that's really a disservice to it but
on the other hand javascript is actually
quite a powerful language in fact it's a
little too powerful for what it can
actually do and it's a dynamically typed
language but it's also weakly typed so
once you get past running the code it's
garbage in garbage out you better know
what kind of objects you are dealing
with otherwise you could get into really
bad errors along the way it's extremely
flexible and in fact very rarely do you
have to really use a framework for
mocking and stuff like that
it's extremely easy to add methods to
classes and and change methods as well
at runtime it does provide functional
style of programming but certainly it's
not a purely functional language in fact
anytime I've heard the word functional
and JavaScript together usually people
say JavaScript is a dysfunctional
language not actually a functional
language but it does have the functional
style of programming in it so you can
use higher-order functions and all those
good stuff but one of the really cool
things about this is you do have
prototypal inheritance well most of the
languages we are used to like for
example Java C++ C sharp we use
class-based inheritance well JavaScript
on the other hand provides a prototype
of inheritance and that's a lot of fun
well let's you know if talking let's
take a look at some examples and see
what we can do with them but I want to
start with some ground rules we have to
be very careful about
now there are a few things that we would
think are optional in JavaScript but
they're optional as in I will hurt you
if you miss using it kind of optional so
one of them is a semicolon let's take a
look at an example here let's say we
have a function called foo well in
programming talks you always have to use
a flu so I took care of that right here
and let's say we have a variable or a
parameter coming in I'm gonna say if n
is less than let's say 5 I simply want
to return in this case the end times 2
let's say and then otherwise I want to
go ahead and say return and of course
otherwise I'm gonna say else and what do
I want to do in the case of L simply
return and itself let's start with this
little example and see what's going to
happen in this particular code well this
looks pretty innocent to begin with
let's go ahead and call this function
let's say foo and send a value of 6 well
clearly you can see that it returned to
6 when we called this function on the
other hand I'm gonna call this function
one more time but this time I'm gonna
send it 3
well of course 3 is less than 5 so we
expect the 3 times 2 which is also a 6
but when I run this little code you can
see it gives us an undefined
in fact why did this actually give us an
undefined well the reason is notice on
line number 3 we don't have a semicolon
well JavaScript says you didn't put a
semicolon let me do you a favor and put
the semicolon for you right it's very
helpful language as you can see well
what logic does JavaScript use well one
another reminder you never use the word
logic and JavaScript on the same line
either so the point really in this case
is JavaScript basically says I'm gonna
take a look at this particular line of
code oh it doesn't have a semicolon I
want to decide whether I should put a
semicolon or not so it looks a little
ahead on the next line of code and says
is this potentially could this be a
standalone expression or statement well
it turns out it can be standalone and so
JavaScript says well since the
can stand alone I'm gonna put a
semicolon right here on the other hand
though had I written this as return n
times to notice that it does produce the
right result because it doesn't make
sense for a star to the stand alone so
JavaScript does not put a semicolon here
instead it puts a semicolon right here
now of course this can be really
annoying to say the least so it's better
to really test the code properly and
make sure we put semicolons and end in
the expressions or statements properly
otherwise we could get into real trouble
with this language well
then comes on one other really charming
feature in the language so for example
if you're writing JavaScript let's say
you wanted to find a variable called
local one equal seven and I want to
print the variable let's say local one
right here and I'm going to call this
function let's say foo doesn't matter
what value I pass to it and of course
when I run this code you can see it
printed seven but I'm gonna ask it to
print local one right here you can see
it gives me an error because I obviously
cannot really access that variable local
variable within the function I cannot
access it right here so that seems to be
really really good so far on the other
hand I'm gonna go back to this code and
say I'm gonna define local two equals
let's say eight I'm gonna print local
due right here and you can see that it's
printing the value of local local two
however notice that in this case I did
not put var in front of local two so
JavaScript looked as this code and says
hey look venket forgot to put var in
front of the variable what's the worst
thing I can do to make them unhappy and
of course you know the worst thing you
can ever imagine as making Global's
variable because that really hurts and
so it decides to make this variable a
global variable as you can see now of
course where this becomes a lot of fun
is when you write code like the
following for example had you written I
equal to zero I less than and I plus
plus and of course in this case let's
say you call another function let's say
f1
and within the function let's say f1
let's say you also have yet another for
loop this is called real fun right now
because when you take this variable I
that's a global variable I basically the
short answer is you're screwed
right try debugging this code it's going
to be an entire afternoon there's a lot
of fun so the only time you don't put
var in your code is if you hate
everybody that you work with otherwise
always put the variable var because it
makes variables global and becomes
really annoying to work with so how do
you really deal with it well one way to
deal with this of course is let's go
back to this code I say in this case
local 2 equals let's say 8 you can see
in this case it made this variable
global well one way to avoid that is to
say you know option use option basically
option strict and you can say in this
case you want to really use the option
strict and you can see that it gives you
an error saying you cannot use the
variable because we haven't defined it
and of course once you define it you get
the error because you cannot access the
variable outside so the point really is
you can't definitely avoid the problem
by using the option string and I
strongly recommend that you write code
JavaScript code using the option strict
that's a really good idea so you can
avoid these kinds of problems quite a
bit in coding and doesn't slip through
so easily so we saw a few problems here
but let's continue a little bit further
let's say I want to write a function how
do you really write a function well I'm
gonna say there are two and a half ways
of writing a function well let's talk
about the first way to write a function
you probably seen this way quite often
and that is you can say in this case
function foo and then of course in this
case I'm gonna simply say foo let's say
are called so this is one way to write a
function and of course you can call the
function right here and that's a common
way we have all seen functions being
defined I'm not a huge fan of this
approach and I'll tell you why I don't
really like this whole lot well what if
I were to say function foo one more time
and in this case of course I'm gonna say
in here let's say foo let's say
redefined over here and of course I'm
gonna call foo one more time now when I
run this code of course the question on
hand is what's the output going to be
well I'll tell you what the output
should be in my own opinion I want this
to produce food called and I want this
to produce who redefined but of course
JavaScript and I rarely agree with each
other so you can see in this case it
produced a very different result now
this is a complete mess but in our field
we do something really well we mess up
so bad but we give beautiful names for
those mess if this call hoisting and so
it doesn't feel that bad anymore so
hoisting basically is it really is
defining a variable at this point for
the function but it's a two pass
evaluation and so it really replaces the
function with the newer definition and
it starts messing things up so we'll get
into some of these problems quite you
know often if we write code like this
well rather than defining a function
this way we could actually define a
function using the VAR keyword and I can
say foo equals function for example here
and this is the option that I actually
prefer for a couple of different reasons
the first reason I prefer this is first
of all it doesn't have the hoisting
problem like we did a few minutes ago
and secondly this keeps it very
consistent in the way you define
functions whether it's anonymous
function or a regular function you
always create an anonymous function and
assign it to a variable so that becomes
a very consistent practice to write the
code so in this case what case what I'm
gonna do is simply say foo called let's
go ahead and say that and I'm gonna call
the function foo but here I'm gonna say
function one more time but in this case
I'm gonna say foo redefined right here
and then of course I'm gonna go ahead
and call the foo function one more time
but notice unlike the previous example
this produces the right result because
you define the variable assigned it to a
function and then you invoke that
variable as a function and then you
reassigned
variable like you normally reassign
variables so this is a very natural way
of doing things there's nothing really
surprising behind the code and in
programming you really want to avoid
surprises as much as you can because the
more surprises the more errors we have
in code as well so that makes it a lot
easier to work with so that gives you an
idea about the second way of writing
code or writing functions and this is
the way I really like to write functions
as well most of the time but then I said
there are two and a half ways of writing
functions what is the other half way
well sometimes people do the following
they say foo equals bar foo equals
function foo and then of course you can
call the function one more time well why
would anybody write the code like that
well people writing this code usually
work for this department called
department of redundancy so you don't
really have to do this so the point
really is they would argue this gives
you a nice way to deal with the
recursive functions but most of those
are really myths and special cases we
really don't have to do this so I would
encourage actually avoiding this case as
well it's not really that much fun to
work with so we saw some of the ways we
can access define the functions but
let's move on to talk about the
parameters the functions actually take
so for this let's take a look at an
example of how we would be working with
a function let's define a function
called max for example and then I'm
going to say this function has a a and B
s two parameters and in this case I'm
gonna say if a is greater than B I want
to simply return a otherwise I want to
simply return let's say the value of B
so let's go ahead and try this max of
let's say 1 & 2 well clearly it gave us
a 2 on the other hand if I say max of
let's say 3 and 1 it also gives us the
value 3 which is correct so everything
seems to be going right just fine but
what if I call max this time but I send
a 1 let's say 3 & 2 well now I'm passing
three parameters wherein I have defined
only two parameter variables at this
point well if you were writing code in
C++ Java or C sharp
at this time you will get a very stern
compilation error saying you are passing
way too many parameters than what is
expected but JavaScript will never ever
scream at you javascript actually treats
you like a guest in its house so it
doesn't really complain in fact when you
look at this you say wow that's awesome
look at produce the right result well
actually not so if you change this to a
seven on the other hand you know it was
just lying so in fact it exactly treats
you like a guest in its house because if
you put the coffee mug in the wrong
place your host doesn't tell you you're
stupid they just smiled to indicate that
you're stupid that's kind of what
JavaScript really does right so it
doesn't really complain on your face but
it misbehaves quietly behind the scenes
but what's really happening in this case
well what's happening in the case of
JavaScript is unlike languages like Java
and c-sharp where the number of
parameters that a function can take is
decided by the function declaration
that's not the case in the case of
JavaScript JavaScript the number of
arguments we can pass to a function is
decided by the color of the function not
the way you are defined it so how many
parameters can I send to a function as
many as you want to send to a function
that's as simple as that well in a way
if you really think about it I could say
for example maybe I know the name of the
first two gentleman here in the front
row but it would be really you know not
right to say there's only two people in
this room because I know these two
people's name obviously there are
several more people I just haven't
gotten to know their name yet in a very
similar way the parameter list can have
as many parameters as you like to have
except that you have given the names for
the first two parameters as a and B in
this case so just quickly to take a look
at an example of this if I were to go
back to this code and print out
arguments well the word arguments is a
keyword in JavaScript that refers to the
arguments that a function is going to
receive at the time of the call so in
this case if a word call let's say max
over here and
two three let's say seven and five you
can see in this particular case that the
function is reporting those as
parameters being passed in on the other
hand if I change this to you know
sending one more thing you can see
that's expanding as well so in other
words while you do have a name a and B
it really doesn't matter these are just
symbolic names for the first few
parameters but the parameter list really
is actually the arguments that you can
actually pass so what you can do in this
code is you can start writing something
along these lines
you could say large is equal to R
Youmans for example and then you can
take the first value zero and then you
could say for instance in this case I
equal to zero I less than argument start
length I plus plus and then of course in
this case you can say if large is less
than arguments of I I can then say large
is equal to arguments of I and you can
see in this case we can write the code
in a very generic manner and so if I
were to of course I want to return the
large finally so let's go ahead and
return the large variable so in this
case you can see if I called max with
one and two like we did before that
seems to be working just fine
let's go ahead and call this with let's
say three and one like we did before
that's working as well but let's go
ahead and call this with a one and let's
say a three and a seven and you can see
that's working as well so you can start
using the arguments of course you may
have to do a bit more error checking to
make sure the arguments is not empty
after all but you can put more logic
after testing that piece of code but
this shows us how the arguments actually
works so the true nature of JavaScript
is you can pass as many arguments to a
function as you want to and that gives
you ultimate freedom and flexibility in
how you want to call the functions but
this also leads us to one other thing
which is a context variable that every
function actually carries so in other
words when you have a function every
function has
implicit this variable that it actually
carries so within a function you can
call upon the dis and sometimes it's
assigned to something you would expect
sometimes it's a saying to something you
didn't expect that's when the fun really
starts that every function has a dis
reference and so it's a context object
that you can actually use now of course
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to
talk about this without really setting a
context so I will talk about this in
combination with the next one I'm gonna
say how do you really call this function
if you are really really interested in
calling the function let's define a
function called greet equals and I'm
gonna say in this case I passed a name
and within this I'm gonna say well hello
and then say plus name and I'm going to
call the greet function let's say greet
and let's go ahead and say Jo right here
and you can see that it says hello Jo
well this is a very common way we are
used to calling functions however there
is one idea in JavaScript which is
pretty different from how we are used to
in Java EE sharpens language like C++ an
even Ruby or most object-oriented
languages for that matter well in most
of the languages a function belongs to a
class so you would say this is an
instance function of this class well
that's not the case in JavaScript in
JavaScript you could be walking along
the beach and you find this beautiful
little function and you say hey you look
really nice I want to own you and you
can take ownership of a random function
and make it part of your object if you
wanted to well how do you do that let me
show you an example of how you can
actually do that so notice what I'm
gonna do here in this code I'm gonna
change this to quietly I'm gonna say
this dart to uppercase now that's a
pretty random little dis start to
uppercase but let's see what that
actually means in this context well when
you call the greet function I am using
the context object called this and then
I'm calling a to uppercase on the
context object so this function doesn't
belong to any class or any object at the
moment but quietly it wishes that it
belongs to and so what you can
do in this case is you would go to this
function and say great and you don't
want to call Joe like this because it's
gonna miserably fail because there is no
function call to uppercase on whatever
that victim object that was associated
with but instead what you can do is you
can do a call over here and the first
parameter I'm gonna say is hello and you
can see how beautifully that became
hello in all uppercase so what is the
difference between directly calling this
function versus using a call function
well the call function well first of all
functions are just objects in JavaScript
and so you went to this function object
and said hey function object I'm not
just gonna call you
I'm gonna first call you by attaching a
context object to you this is an
extremely powerful feature because you
can take any function and you can give
an association of the function to
another context we're gonna see how this
comes into play in just a few minutes so
in this case we took hello as the
context object now clearly if I call
greet at this point and call hello and
I'm gonna say howdy comma let's say J
and over here and you can see in this
case it became howdy Jane so we call
exactly the same function twice but we
have established a different context
object each of the time so the call
function takes n plus 1 parameters so if
you have n parameters you would pass n
plus 1 where the first parameter becomes
your context object that you're gonna
pass to this particular function now
clearly while this is working just fine
for us let's say we have names equal to
and let's say in this case we have a
collection of names let's say our good
friends Tom and Jerry right here and I
want to call this function how would I
call this well we could say dart call
and then sadly I would have to say in
this case hi comma and the name square
brackets 0 and the names square bracket
1 which is kind of silly if you really
think about it and of course I have two
names that I'm gonna pass n let's go
ahead and change the function to say I
want to pass two names in this case so I
have a name 1
right here and named - and of course I
could say name oneplus and let's say
name - well if you notice in this
particular example we called the Tom &
Jerry as two parameters but I really
don't want to take a wonderful array and
start splitting them into these
individual values which kind of doesn't
really favor a good fluent code well
thankfully we don't have to do this
that's exactly what apply is for so
apply and call has only one difference
they both take the first parameter as
the context parameter so notice in this
case I said hi but apply takes an array
of values whereas call takes discrete
values so if you already have a
collection of objects you can't really
use the apply and pass the collection
rather than having to split them into
pieces so depending on what you're
trying to do you can either use the call
function or the apply function and you
can use either one of them if you want
to just pass an array use the apply if
you want to just pass discrete values
then use the call function it becomes
very easy to work with it as you can see
so we saw quite a few things already we
saw how to set a context object using
call how to set a context object using
apply we saw that the context object
itself is that this within the function
we're going to put all of these together
in what we're gonna see moving forward
but let's take a quick break and talk
about a few interesting things before we
get back to that well you can use higher
order functions very effectively so for
example if you're using a collection of
values let's say list is equal to let's
say 1 2 & 3 and I want to either rate
and print the values in this list well
if I want to iterate and print the
values in this particular list you could
have said for VAR I equal to zero I less
then list art length well this is very
really boring we don't have to do this
thankfully we can say let's start for
each and we can then specify a function
we can say here is an element and I can
simply ask it to print the element out
from this particular collection we could
use a code like this a functional style
I
wish more people would write code like
this in JavaScript because JavaScript
has all the functional style functions
in fact I would argue a JavaScript
actually has some better functions than
both c-sharp and Java actually have in
terms of some of the beautiful things
you can do with this well I don't want
to just bring the values I want to print
a double of the values well clearly we
can do that easily here all I have to do
is simply say math and given a function
with the element e return e times two
and you can see that in this case I'm
actually printing the double of the
values rather than just printing the
values notice how concise the code is
with the functional style that we can
begin to write the code very easily but
I don't want to print the double of all
the values I want to print the double of
only even values in the collection well
very simple we can tag along one more
function a filter function we're given
an element I'm going to say return
element mark two is equal to zero and
you can see that in this case we are
printing only the double of the even
values in the collection so you can see
that you can write pretty much a
functional style of code in JavaScript
nothing stops you from really making use
of it in fact moving into JavaScript or
Ekman script 2015 this is going to
become only better because the way this
code is going to change in X Muscatine
is you're going to change this to a E
and you're going to simply say in this
case e Mar 2 is equal to 0 and the
syntax becomes a lot lighter as you can
see that is echo my script 2016 syntax
so the code doesn't smell as much moving
forward and you can also benefit from
this also here as you can see this is
again an external script syntax where
you can say return the double of the
value so you can see the code is
becoming a lot lighter in terms of the
syntax itself and likewise here also I
can remove that function and I can
simply put a little lambda or they call
it as an arrow function and you can use
that very readily as you can see the
code becomes a lot more concise moving
into atmosphere 2016 so this is a really
a good direction to move forward and the
code becomes very concise as you can see
that you can
from so we saw the functional style of
code but I want to talk about one caveat
we gotta be very careful when we work
with JavaScript so if you ever talk
about math or you know concepts in
arithmetic you've got to be very careful
when you're dealing with JavaScript so
for example let's say a is equal to 1
and I'm gonna print the value of a you
can see it's a 1 I'm gonna now say in
this case ask for a variable B equals to
1 so in this case of course the value of
B is a 1 as well I'm gonna now define C
equals 1.0 and of course I'm gonna print
the value of C as well and you can see
that's the value that I printed but now
I'm going to say hey JavaScript tell me
something is a equal to B and JavaScript
faithfully says of course it is great
thank you
now I'm gonna say is B is equal to C and
JavaScript says of course it's true now
this is where you get really wrong
because you're mixing JavaScript and
logic and now we are saying if a is
equal to b and b is equal to c then of
course a should be equal to C and
JavaScript say is now right
so you never show this to children
because they will lose faith in every
civilization in the world that we have
really created so far right
so you can see this is completely
illogical but why and the reason for
that is the double equals is absolutely
messed up and if you look at code on the
web including my own code most of it is
absolutely wonk and the reason is our
double equals does not do comparison it
does comparison by converting types of
objects which is not what you really
want most of the time so how do you
really fix it the first rule is do not
use double equals anymore so instead
what you do is you can use 3 equals if
anybody asks you why tell them you're
really cool because you like to use 3
equals rather than two equals well you
can see in this case
consistently says false for all of those
things because obviously the type is
different and the only time a triple
equals is going to give you the right
result is when the type is first of all
the same and then the value is equal if
the type is not the same it's going to
give you a false to begin with so you
don't have the mess that we ran into
likewise if you want to use the not
equals so for example if you were to say
a is not equal to B notice it tells you
false in this case but it should be
really true because a is really not
equal to B so in this case you want to
use the X excuse me exclamation and two
equals and that is basically the syntax
for comparing not equals as well so
that's the right syntax you really want
to use three equals versus a exclamation
and 2w equals that's basically syntax
you want to use to do the comparisons
and not comparison as well well we
talked about a few pitfalls you got to
be careful with but let's talk about
functions as objects first of all and
functions are really objects and objects
could be functions as well so it treats
that very interchangeably and of course
these can have properties as well we
already saw this a few minutes ago you
are able to call the call method on the
function you were able to call the apply
method on the function so that uses a
clue that functions are kind of like
objects they carry a few methods or
functions with it
but I want to focus on creating an
object right now well one of the really
nice things I like about JavaScript is
you don't need to create classes if you
really want to create objects you can
readily create objects very easily so
let's take a look at an example here I'm
gonna say Sam equals and I've created an
object here I'm gonna say first name for
Sam let's say that's our first name last
name let's say in this case last name
I'm gonna give for the Sam and I'm gonna
say age is gonna be a little age value
now you can see in this case I can print
the variable Sam well that's object
obviously I can call upon the age of Sam
and print the age of Sam but I can also
say Sam dot play and I can invoke a
function on Sam as well so in this case
go ahead and create a play function
which is simply a function itself and
I'm going to simply say let's say
playing right here and you can see that
I'm able to call that function on this
particular object well we know this has
JSON object so we can create JSON
objects and easily pass them around so
it's a very lightweight syntax it
doesn't burden you to create classes
before you can have objects so a lot of
times I don't even bother creating
classes I just create objects and float
them around and that becomes a lot
easier to work with so you can readily
create objects but one really nice
feature that you can have on these
objects is the concept of prototype so
what is a prototype well a prototype
basically is an object think of this
like a bag if you want to think about it
so for example let's say you come to me
and say hey can have a change for euros
please well sure I can give you a change
for euros because I've got some euros in
my wallet I can give you change for
euros but if I if you ask me can I have
change for some dollars please I don't
really have a reason to carry dollars
this week I could say no to you but
instead of saying no to you I'm gonna go
and reach into this wonderful bag which
carries every other junk that I own and
if I reach into it I can get you the
change for dollars so the point really
is I have to really reach into my wallet
but often time I can reach into my bag
as well and you can think of this as a
prototype so a prototype think of it as
a backpack that every object carries
around except that that prototype in
JavaScript is really cool because that
backpack has another backpack
potentially and that keep going until
there's no backpack so the point really
is you can have a chain of these
prototypes really nicely so notice what
I'm gonna do here I'm gonna go to this
particular object and Sam is really too
young but let's get rid of the age for a
minute and let's say in this case worker
and I'm gonna say worker is equal to and
right a function here let's go ahead and
defined the function as a work function
and in this case it's a function and
it's simply going to say let's say a
working now you can see I have a little
Sam object on my hand and I'm going to
go ahead and call a function let's say
you Sam that's a really poor name for a
function but anyway I'm gonna pass the
object instance we'll call it a use
function and I'm gonna pass the instance
and I'm gonna say dry and let's say
catch exception and I'm gonna print the
details of the exception well in this
case I'm gonna say instant dart work
well you clearly can see our little Sam
doesn't have a work method right now so
I'm gonna call use and sense and Sam to
it and you can see that it immediately
says in start work is not a function so
I got an error saying I don't have a
function after all called work well it's
clear that Sam doesn't have a work
function but notice what I'm gonna do
now I'm going to say Sam dart proto and
then I'm gonna say equals and in this
case I'm going to set the worker as the
prototype if you will so what I just did
is I took over Sam object and assign the
prototype of the Sam to the worker
object that we had right now so this is
like attaching a backpack to little Sam
and say here you go now I call the use
function and pass the object Sam but
notice this time it doesn't give us an
error instead it says working now this
is an extremely powerful concept as you
can see why because I can also do the
following a mock worker and then equal
to I can say work and this could be a
nice mark function I could create for
instance and then I could say you know
pretend to work this is a nice feature
to have some days and then of course I
can say Sam dart proto
is equal to mark worker and you Sam in
this case and you can see it says
pretend to work so it's extremely simple
to modify the prototype so testing
becomes incredibly simple the minute we
start engaging prototypes and I employee
this
lot of times when I do automated testing
automated unit testing for JavaScript I
often create a proxy object refer to my
main object and then during testing I
hijack functions on the main object by
introducing a middle prototype so this
becomes very convenient for doing
automated testing of code that's a
really powerful way to deal with things
very quickly so this gives us an idea
about how we can actually use the
prototype on objects and benefit from
that very powerfully but let's take this
concept one more further down
how about creating classes well let's
create a class called car so I'm gonna
say car function and there you go we
created a class you say wait a minute
you created a function no trust me we
created a class if you don't believe me
did you know this the uppercase C well
that's a convention that JavaScript
follows which is kind of silly but this
is what is so beautiful right when
you're a programmer you never look at
code you see code and and these case
differences are really really important
for us programmers the non programmers
would look at us and say you guys are
weird
but that's the world we live in and this
means a lot to us well in JavaScript the
case that you assign for a function
decides whether it is a regular function
or it's a class but actually let's be
honest about this JavaScript doesn't
have classes so what in the world is
this well if I say a lowercase C I
simply wrote a regular function if I put
an uppercase C I simply wrote a factory
function in other words this is nothing
but a constructor that you are writing
so in JavaScript you never write classes
you always write a constructor and a
constructor can produce the object for
you now in this case of course I'm gonna
say year and this start year equals the
year value now you know where that this
comes into play it's a context object on
which I want to set this but how do I go
about use
I'm gonna say in this case let's call as
car created let's go ahead and use this
function I can say car like this but
don't do this now note this javascript
doesn't complain but what you just did
here is you just call the constructor
function directly and JavaScript kind of
looks at you and says that's silly and
it still lets you do stuff right it
never ever complains as you know so this
is really meaningless to call it this
way but you could if you really wanted
to it doesn't care but the way really
you want to call this is you want to say
car 1 equals new car 2015 and that's
exactly what you want to do now if you
say car 1 dot here you can see that
object was created but you also have the
year value in place but let's understand
the meaning of this piece of code what
does this new stuff really mean and it's
actually very simple to think about it
is a three-step process what just
happened here and we already covered all
the three steps so it should be very
easy for us to understand what's going
on in this code the very first step is
memory is allocated for the instance
let's call that call that inst so you
have a little instance a memory has been
allocated for that instance what does it
do next the second thing it does is it
calls in this case so calls what is it
called well instant dot call well pardon
me a card are called instance comma 2015
so it makes a call to the call method
and passes that memory instance as a
context object and says go ahead and run
this in the context of that so now you
know why on line number two this dot
here is setting the object's parameter
because that becomes the context object
the third step here is instant start
proto
is equal to card art prototype so you
can see what's the last step in this in
this case it takes the object you
created and assigns the prototype of the
object to be the prototype of the
function itself on the object it's
called underscore underscore proto on
the class well the constructor it's
called fully spelled word prototype so
there shows a few things for us when you
create multiple objects the multiple
objects actually share the same
prototype and this is a very powerful
concept because Java Script can create
hundreds and thousands of objects but
the objects actually share the prototype
and that can be very efficient in memory
as well and so this is called the
prototype L inheritance so in Java and
c-sharp we are used to class-based
inheritance where a class inherits from
another class in the case of JavaScript
you have prototypal inheritance where an
object inherits its stuff from a
prototype instance this is a very
powerful inheritance model class-based
inheritance is rather static and very
limiting prototypal inheritance he is
extremely powerful and flexible it's
really a shame that we don't use this
really that often in a lot of languages
but this is one of the most charming
features of JavaScript is the prototypal
inheritance that you have available in
the object now let's talk about what
this means when it comes to creating
these objects so notice in this case I'm
gonna create an object car 1 and you can
see that I have a year for the car 1 but
let's do something a little different
I'm gonna say car dot prototype dart and
I'm gonna say miles equal to 0 so notice
how I created a little miles within the
prototype and so this miles
is part of the prototype and I'm gonna
say car dot prototype dot Drive equals 2
function and in this case I'm gonna say
that my drive function is going to take
a distance over here and then of course
say this start miles plus equal to
distance I apologize I have to use miles
because my brain is wired to miles and
not kilometers so sorry your car is
gonna be better than mine obviously
it'll have kilometers than miles but
mine sucks okay so right there is the
miles value I'm gonna say well how does
this really work let's talk about this
for a minute and see how this is gonna
behave right now so you can see I have a
mild so have a drive all those good
stuff but before we go any further let's
save our car to equals new car 2017 well
let's say 2016 it's a brand new car it's
November we can have new cars great now
I'm gonna say a output in this case car
to dart year and clearly you can see
that year values are different I'm gonna
remove this message so we see less
output on the screen so you can see
those two ears being printed let's look
at something else real quick I'm gonna
say car one dart proto is equal to car
let's say to dart proto well question
for you what do you think is the answer
to our faults I'll give you a clue it's
either true or false what do you think
true absolutely because remember the
three steps we talked about when you
create car one each prototype points two
cars prototype when you create car two
what does it do its prototype points two
cars prototype so both of them have
exactly the same prototype well wait a
minute let's now ask the question car
one dart miles is zero let's ask the
question car to dart miles zero that
makes sense so far now I say car one dot
drive ten and I'm gonna ask for car one
dart miles
hey that's ten now I'm gonna say car to
dart miles oh my goodness what do you
think would you be happy if car two
moved when car one mood that's called
you do right that's not programming so
our logic seems to be in trouble right
because we just said the objects are
shared but what do we do now let's
understand this with a little example
could you kindly volunteered for me
would even be helpful you can see you
can sit there and you can be happily sit
there what's your name sir Alex you are
my volunteer everybody knows this right
you are accepting great so alex is my
volunteer and Alex you're my prototype
all right so here's my prototype is
pointing to it what is your name sir
what's your name Enbridge well our good
friend comes to me and he says my god
I'm in a rush could I please borrow a
dollar from you he seems like a nice guy
anybody can vouch for it okay all right
so I propose being built up so here's my
dollar for you pick it and about two
hours goes by he comes back and returns
my dollar thank you sir
you're a nice person I put in my wallet
so everything went fine but something
else happened we now built a trust you
are trustworthy right so two days goes
by he comes to me and says you've been
such a great help two days ago but I'm
in real trouble could I please borrow
hundred dollars from you right now
trustworthy seems like but there's a
problem I don't have hundred dollars on
me what do you think I should do as my
prototype Alex there we go I got it from
Alex I give it to him here you go two
days goes by guy is still trustworthy he
gives me $100 can somebody suggest what
should I do with this $100 keep it
that's right does anybody have a problem
with it
I'm not looking at Alex obviously right
well if you understood what I just did
you understood how JavaScript works so
in JavaScript this is a fundamental
concept gets our B
four sets are shallow so notice what I
did when he came to me and said can I
get hundred dollars from you please you
know what I don't have hundred dollars
gets our deeper I go to my prototype and
say Alex could I can I have the money
please well Alex may not have the money
what is he gonna do go to his prototype
right and behind them is a big Swiss
bank so we all can get the money right
but the sets are shallow which means
when you come to set it I'm not gonna go
any deeper I'm just gonna keep it so now
when you go back and ask the question
hey what does car do not miles notice
the answer is still zero why because car
drive drive said this start miles but
what in the world is this this is a
context object in this case the context
object is the car object not the
prototype so as a result it was set on
the instance not on the prototype so
that is the magic behind how JavaScript
very efficiently shares the objects but
it doesn't mess up the shared state
because it goes people to get the
objects when it doesn't exist but when
you do a set it sets on the object never
goes down to the prototypes please well
actually you do you don't have it you
actually have it this but the difference
in at mask of 2015's functions and arrow
functions both have a dis except that in
the case of arrow function you are this
is actually tied to the context of where
you come from whereas these this are
very different so it doesn't really
solve this problem still this actually
this is not even a problem this is a
feature don't blame it as a problem okay
so the point is it should behaves
properly so the fact that this is out of
bounds or context is a separate problem
than this one well this takes us to the
next level
notice how this actually nicely deals
with it
so that
gets our deeper and sets are shallow and
that's basically how they're sharing
happens whatever be nice to really take
a look at this so how do we really
understand this is actually working the
way it's a poster so to understand this
let's do the following I'm gonna go to
this object and say hey object I want to
examine your properties after all so I'm
gonna say barb
over here VAR and I'm gonna ask for the
property on this object prop let's say
prop in car one and I'm gonna simply
print out the property that I have on my
hand you can see it's a liar it tells
that it's got properties so you can come
to me and say Venkat are you rich
and I would say of course I am because
I've got Alex who in turn has a big bank
behind him right but then you say
Beckett are you really rich well that's
a different story
right so the point really is that I can
actually look for all the properties but
I can now say well but tell me is that
really your property and so that's a
very different question as you can see
so if I go to the property plus and I'm
gonna now ask it car one that has owned
property prob you can see it's a false
four-year I'm sorry miles and drive
because those two properties actually
come from the prototype and not from the
real object itself on the other hand if
I were to say car one dot drive ten and
and now you can see that I've actually
called the drive function on it now if I
go back and ask the question or are you
are these your properties notice how
miles went from false to true and that's
because remember sets are shallow so
before the call of the drive function
the property miles was in the prototype
but when you call the drive function the
property becomes property of the object
and it's still in the prototype but it's
also on the object so when you ask and
use it your own property you can say it
says true
rather than saying false and that's when
the set happened in the same time though
had you created your car to sew car a to
equals new car as we did before 2016 as
you can see here but now in this case if
I were to ask the same question of car
two you will notice that in in here this
is for car two as you can see it says
miles is actually true well did I say
the car too so this is going to be car
two and this is going to be car too
obviously so you can see in this case
it's a false because car two doesn't
have the property it still reaches into
its prototype but car 1 has the property
so there shows you how you can actually
get these properties now one question
you may have is hey this is nice that we
are able to bring the property on to
this particular object so for example in
this case if I say car one dot Drive 10
and you can see in this case car 1 dart
has own property so we can say property
so let's go ahead and ask for it so for
let's say bar prop it comes from car 1
and I'm going to print in this case the
property itself plus let's go ahead and
say this is going to be car Wonder has
own property and you can see in this
case miles is actually going to be part
of this object car 1 let's make sure
that I'm doing this right and the
property itself I want to pass through
this so you can see in this case miles
is part of the object well that's
because of course we call the drive
function so at this point the car 1 has
the property now here is one feature
I'll quickly mention but be very careful
sometimes I use this during testing
purpose but I would say almost never in
production and that is you can say
delete car one dart miles and you can
ask it to delete the property now I
recommend you don't use delete because
if you do it can be very confusing so
you're basically going to this object
and knocking that property off and of
course once you don't have the property
if you ask for a get on it it will go to
get it from the prototype if it is there
that's a bit confusing and error-prone
but can be fairly useful during testing
purposes but I would very rarely go that
route and use this during production so
be very careful about it so the summary
is what we talked about we looked at a
number of features here of JavaScript
JavaScript actually is a very powerful
language I really really like this
language quite a lot and it's a language
that is very powerful but you have to
really use it properly and by using it
properly you can actually benefit from
some really really powerful features for
example the context object is something
I've used quite often the call comes in
very handy when you are trying to build
a fairly complex set of objects if you
ever take a look at any of the
JavaScript libraries out there we are
going to readily start looking at
functions like call and apply being used
quite often so this becomes very
powerful features to use but the most
charming feature in my opinion is the
prototypal inheritance and once we learn
about prototypal inheritance you also
learn that JavaScript classes are never
closed you can always go to a JavaScript
object and add methods remove methods
change methods or change functions so
the objects are always open for
extension and that gives you enormous
power on your hand to work with
javascript so things like mocking and
testing is incredibly easy in JavaScript
and JavaScript of course being a
language which is so flexible it is
really unfortunate if we write code in
JavaScript without testing it so
javascript actually makes testing
extremely easy but it also is a language
that demands enormous amount of testing
and I think that's only fair that
reduces the flexibility and demands you
know you to really use it so that's a
really good game in my opinion so it's a
very powerful language as I said it's a
language that really is probably the
most ubiquitous language we ever use it
only is a good idea for us to take the
time to learn the power of this language
and I hope you found the session useful
thank you
[Applause]